[Musique]
en ethiopie les vivres continuent
d'arriver pour venir en aide aux
victimes de la famine à ce jour ce sont
7 millions de personnes qui sont ainsi
menacées par la faim et la malnutrition
un problème extrêmement douloureux dans
un pays où l'on estime le nombre de
victimes à 300 milles depuis neuf mois
aujourd'hui l'effort international est
très important mais toujours insuffisant
il est responsable les éthiopiens lancer
un nouveau cri d'alarmé devant la
rupture des stocks nous avons un
témoignage à vous présenter ce soir sur
la situation dans ce pays du bout du
monde ce témoignage c'est celui d'un
responsable des nations unies qui
revient justement d'ethiopie écoutez le
et ce pays vous paraîtra peut-être plus
proche de nous
dans quelques heures ce bébé sera mort
c'est une certitude
comme celui là ils sont plus de 500
mille ans passés ici dans ce camp au
nord d'addis abeba
la famine de cette année est l'une des
plus grandes du siècle
ils meurent en masse depuis six mois
ici c'est la solution de la dernière
chance qu'une sonde pour nourrir de
force ce corps abandonnés
[Musique]
l'image qui me reste encore à l'esprit
c'est celle de cette jeune mère qui se
précipitent vers nous à mon arrivée et
qui me dit quand mon enfant avec toi je
n'ai plus de quoi lui donner à manger je
ne veux pas qu'il meure dans mes bras
elle me suivait elle me suivait et
soudain j'ai vu l'enfance à venir pris
de panique je les prix j'ai commencé à
courir vers la tente médicale trop tard
et les mois de l'année bras l'histoire
de cet enfant qui avait trois ans et qui
pesait 4 kg alors que la plupart des
bébés dans les pays occidentaux pèse 3
kilos et demi et 4 kg à la naissance
donc l'histoire de cet enfant est aussi
une histoire de 15000 personnes qui
meurent de faim chaque semaine en
ethiopie évidemment il est très
difficile d'établir des statistiques
parce que la plupart des populations
sont dans des régions inaccessibles mais
il est sûr que la sécheresse menace
aujourd'hui plus de 7 millions de
personnes
et de fait c'est tout le nord de ce pays
grand comme deux fois la france qui est
sinistrée
ce qui complique l'acheminement de
l'aide internationale
c'est que les zones les plus touchées
sont celles où la guérilla érythréenne
et tigréenne opposent une résistance
farouche aux armes et d'addis abeba
[Musique]
pourtant depuis quelques semaines l'aide
alimentaire commence à arriver dans ces
provinces
les centaines de milliers de tonnes de
poudre de lait de sucre et de céréales
mais c'est loin d'être suffisant
m pour vous donner une idée depuis
l'explosion des médias à anvers
l'ethiopie en octobre dernier la
communauté internationale a promis 190
mille tonnes de céréales alors que selon
le gouvernement égyptien rien que pour
couvrir les besoins de 50% de la
population il faut cinq cent soixante
trois mille tonnes de céréales
quelle que soit l'aide internationale on
sait déjà que 900 mille hommes femmes et
enfants mourront d'ici noël
[Musique]